parler d'un truc là les gars c'est pas
le même pas la même limonade vous avez
vu cette histoire là les images
apocalyptiques en Chine ah oui après
l'apparition d'un nouveau virus doit-on
craindre le pire ça c'est une bonne rass
4 ans après l'apparition du covid-19 une
vague de maladie respiratoire est
actuellement en train de toucher la
Chine des images de plus en plus
inquiétantes des hôpitaux chinois fond
surface et on possé l'OMS l'Organisation
Mondiale de la Santé adressé une demande
officielle à la Chine pour obtenir des
informations détaillées sur cette vague
de maladie comment s'en protéger est-ce
que ça va arriver en France est-ce que
c'est une épidémie mondiale éire
brunoban sera avec nous chef du service
réanimation alors il est toujours Bruno
à chaque fois faut que tu me
redises il est avec nous juste après
parce que il m'a dit lanière fois allez
c'est parti les pleur de cette jeune
fille malade assise ici depuis trop
longtemps dans cet hôpital de shanghï
une foule danse de parents et d'enfants
inquiet un afflux de patients dû à une
maladie respiratoire qui semble toucher
de nombreux mineurs constat est
similaire ailleurs dans le pays comme
ici dans cet hôpital de Pékin où les
fils d'attente s'allongent de son côté
l'OMS s'inquiète et a demandé à la Chine
des informations détaillées sur la
situation cette alerte intervient 4 ans
après l'apparition d'une mystérieuse
pneumonie viral devenu la pandémie de
covid-19 merci Bruno meggarban d'être
avec nous chef du service de réanimation
à l'hôpital laariboisierre excellent
l'hôpital est excellent chef de service
Bruno on aime toujours quand il vient
nous voir et là on a besoin de vous
informer là-dessus parce qu'on a très
peur euh qu'est-ce qui se passe que
sa-on pour l'instant de ces maladies là
parce que ça commence à me moi je tousse
un peu déjà je me dis ça y est c'est sûr
je suis comme les comme les Chinois là
donc c'est quoi l'histoire alors vous
avez raison on observe une augmentation
euh du nombre de personnes qui
consultent dans les services d'urgence
et à l'hôpital ou ici euh en Chine euh
alors ceci coïncide avec une période où
il fait beaucoup plus froid dans le nord
de la Chine et où donc un certain nombre
de virus ou de bactéries responsables
des pneumonies hivernales circule de
façon plus importante et donc c'est ce
phénomène qui est que l'on observe sur
les différentes images rapporté par la
télévision le problème évidemment c'est
que la Chine explique très peu ce qui se
passe et
donc par crainte de ce qui s'est passé
il y a 4 ans c'est ça et bien on
suspecte éventuellement un nouveau agent
infectieux mais en fait très
probablement il ne s'agit pas d'une
épidémie liée à un seul agent infectieux
un agent nouveau mais en fait une
circulation plus importante des agents
habituels des infections hivernales
alors on va se poser les questions que
tout le monde se pose est-ce que ça va
arriver en France est-ce que c'est
est-ce qu'on a on est en droit de
s'inquiéter regardez depuis plusieurs
jours les hôpitaux de certaines régions
chinois sont débordés et certaines
images de foule ont été filmées regardez
cette
raide
voilà énorme Haida en Chine euh donc euh
c'est c'est quoi en fait c'est quoi
alors ça n'est pas habituel c'est il y a
un peu plus de personnes que d'habitude
euh malgré tout aujourd'hui il n'y a
aucune évidence pour penser qu'il y a
l'émergence d'un nouvel agent infectieux
mais pourquoi tout le monde a déjà
entendu ça quoi c'est les mêmes mots que
quand on avait eu le le covid on a des
médecins qui venaient non ne vous
inquiétez pas il y a aucune chance que
ça arrive c'est une gripette là vous
citez Michel SIM les gars là on a je
malgré tout malgré tout dis tu c'est
faire là voilà malgré tout les autorités
sanitaires chinoises ne voudraient pas
faire la même chose et donc évidemment
il surveille les choses mais c'est vrai
qu'il ne communique pas comme un pays
démocratique
habituel même si pour le moment il
laisse penser que l'un des agents est le
microplasma pneumonié qui est un une
bactérie habituelle qui a notamment les
enfants l'hiver qui est plutôt
responsable de on va dire de
rinopharingite de bronchite voire de
pneumonie plutôt bénigne d'ailleurs
souvent qui guériss spontanément mais
qui reste sensible aux antibiotiques que
l'on peut donner oui donc là ça veut
dire que ça ça ça ça atteindrait plus
plus précisément les moins de 15 ans
alors plus effectivement on observe en
fait que c'est plutôt les enfants qui
sont atteints alors 15 ans alors moins
de 15 ans donc on va dire l'une des
explications aussi c'est que il faut
savoir c'est le premier hiver euh où
effectivement les Chinois n'ont plus les
mesures restrictives très importantes
qu'ils avaient pour la pour la stratégie
du covid0 mais on va pas s'il y a un
truc qui se passe en Chine on sait très
bien que ça va arriver en France hein
alors oui on observe déjà en France on
observe déjà en France notamment parmi
les enfants une augmentation des appels
euh à l'hôpital les appels de SOS
médecin pour peut relier des infections
respiratoiresier à
probablement c'est le même phénomène on
observe aussi une augmentation des cas
d'infection à mycoplasma pneumon chez
les enfants ah oui bah oui c'est chaud
prof alors la question de Pascal la T du
pas qu'on attend tous les soirs non
arrête alors avancez-vous avancez-vous
quand même docteur docteur non
professeur professeur la question
c'était surtout la résistance aux
antibiotiques moi c'est ça qui non tu
trouves pas la résistance aux
antibiotiques des des enfants qui qui
qui pose question c'est pas tant les
infections respiratoires mais cette
fois-ci une résistance aux antibiotiques
est-ce que c'est vrai ça c'est avéré
chez nous
alors ce germe là notamment le
mycoplasma pneumoni est un germe dit
atypique il est généralement sensible à
une classe d'antibiotiqu que l'on
appelle les macrolides et à ce jour il
n'y a aucune évidence pour penser que
c'est cette bactérie est devenue
résistante à ces
antibioti augtin et tout le reste non
pas augmenttin
justement alors clamoxy clxy c'est bon
non plus non plus justement cette
famille d'antibiotique ne marche pas sur
ce type de B alors il faut prendre
lesquel il faut prendre rovamicine
rovamicine il joue toujours au Spartac
Moscou est-ce que vous pensez que ça
serait raisonnable ou souhaitable qu'on
qu'on qu'on remette des masques alors
c'est une très bonne question donc
effectivement avec on va dire
l'augmentation d'incidence des
infections respiratoires donc comme je
l'ai même au virus habituel les
personnes les plus âgées restent plus
sensibles que ce soit la grippe que ce
soit le VRS virus respiratoire sinctial
que ce soit la covid que ce soit le
myicoplasma pneumoni
les personnes âé qui ont des
comorbidités qui sont immunodéprimés
restent plus âgé reste plus fragile et
donc de fait effectivement on va dire il
est recommandé tout d'abord aux
personnes qui ont des signes cliniques
de fi ou de syndrome gripal et bien
d'être un peu plus prudent de mettre un
masque quand ils vont voir les autres
quand ils vont au travail donc et puis
pour ceux qui sont fragiles bah de
mettre le masque dans les lieux publics
clos notamment les transports en
j'étais très bien qu'est-ce qui vous
arrive et puis enfin Rapp quand M que
quand je pense à ça je tousse moi je
rappele rappelez quand même qu' je crois
que j'ai une araigné dans dans
le rappelez qu'on est encore pas on va
dire à la vague de l'épidémie de grippe
et de covid qui va arriver généralement
fin décembre début janvier et donc il
est encore temps de se faire vacciner
pour éviter d'être infecté de développer
une infection nor pour pour covri pour
la gripe et pour le covid faut faire
vaccin de quoi grippe et covid alors
idéalement les deux mais on va dire
notamment lorsqu'on est on a plus de 60
ans on est fragile avec des commorbidité
lorsqu'on est immunodéprimé maintenant
pour tous ceux pour tous ceux c'est
ouvert à tout le monde pour tous ceux
qui veulent éviter le développer des
formes passer gauche cette hiver là on
écoute le docteur et de
covidà donc à la même à la même au même
moment on peut avoir les deux vaccins
l'un dans l'épaule droite l'autre dans
l'épaule ga bah voilà vous faites
fa pas grand chose de vos
épules
juste docteur professeur pourquoi ça
vient toujours de Chine alors c'est une
bonne question on va dire exactement
sont plus
nombreux alors on va dire d'abord parce
que la population est plus nombreuse ce
qu' dit le routier là ensuite ce qu' dit
bison il y 2 minutes beaucoup de
réservoirs de de ces virus sont des
réservoirs animaux et il se trouve qu'en
Chine effectivement il y a une certaine
Pr miscuité dans l'habitat entre les
humains et les animaux et de fait
effectivement et bien ces animaux
servent en fait de réservoir où les
nouveaux virus annuels émergent et donc
contaminent les personnes et à ce
moment-là on a l'p covid on alors la
covid c'est un peu différent parce que
lui c'était un nouveau virus lui ça a
été la rencontre entre une chauve souris
et l'homme ça c'est quelque chose
d'assez exceptionel Batman quoi en fait
quelque part quel part a eu un vecteur
intermédiaire mais très probablement
cette rencontre s faite peut-être
directement peut-être laboratoire de
virologie de Wan làdessus il y a un
mystère ou peut-être naturellement dans
une gr aè encore
myèreig il y a plein de questions
mais com donnez-moi les questions je
vais dire comment on tort le coup
coptist disent en ce moment il disent en
ce moment ils ont essayé avec les vieux
ça pas marché maintenant il attaque aux
enfant alors il va répondre dans un
instant Bruno vous allez répondre dans
un instant vous restez avec nous dans un
instant on va revenir bien sûr bonne
question hein pas mal sur parce qu'il
faut tre le coup voilà bah tu fais comme
ça
et on va revenir sur tout ça les chéris
à tout de suite c'est important